magnus carlsen against alireza farusha
the dream encounter an encounter that we
always look forward to and once again
it did not disappoint so with an
opponent like alireza ferruccio's
notoriously known for his ability to
stop
tac to spot tactics in literally every
single position
it is certainly not an easy task for for
even the world champion
he chose this time a fairly solid
approach and did his best to avoid
any complications and with great success
we're going to see how the game played
out so
magnus played uh d4 knight of six from
ferruccia
c4 e6 knight c3
very very common opening i can mention
that bishop e4 here is uh perhaps even
more common than what
alairis did here known as the nimso
indian defense
without the rest of light e5 take stakes
bishop g5 this is known as the
the main line c6 e3
h6 bishop h4
it should be seven from ole resa is now
out of the out of the pin bishop d3 from
uh
magnus very very logical castles and
here magnus plays a
strange move a move i've never seen
before
and that is bishop g3 and
uh i do believe that he did this
just to confuse lrs a little bit because
he knows that he just
uh he just wants to get already out of
book he wants alaresa to to start
thinking
for um for himself instead of just
playing
theoretical moves and then make a draw
because
this line is very very very solid and if
you know your theory
a lot of pieces usually get exchanged
and the
positions become fairly fairly dull
so bishop g3 from from magnus not bd7
h3 the point of this move is that magnus
wants to give
his bishop to h2 square so for example
if he had played a knight e2 here
it would have been possible for a
laressa to play a knight h5
and thus uh allareza will win the
the bishop pair keep in mind that this
also happens usually when
when even magnus has his bishop on h4
just to trade off a pair of bishops
so that means that knight h5 there would
have been even stronger and perhaps
lressa would have been better than
so that's why mangus plays uh h3
rookie eight knight of three and here
alaresa goes for
bishop b4 which i think is a fairly
fairly good move
he wants to pin the knight and he's also
looking at ideas like 94 and the near
future
as as well magnus played at queen b3
and on the rest it played an interesting
move and more dynamic move
we know that alers's style is very very
dynamic
and that is c5 attacking
magnus's center and also protecting the
bishop
i do believe however that it probably
would have been better to simply take on
c3 and then play knight e4
but perhaps lrs i was slightly afraid
that
you know this is a kind of a magnus-like
position
a position where it's seemingly equal
but
you know that at some point he's going
to create
some mass some stuff and he's slightly
better and then he wins
just like it he has he has done so many
times so that's why
alareza probably wanted to make it
slightly more complicated but
unfortunately i think he just simply
made it
more complicated for for himself so
castles takes takes and the difference
here with knight e4
is that he doesn't really have such a
good grip
in the center with the pawn on c6 he
hasn't
he's controlling d5 the d5 square very
nicely
but if we have a trade like this magnus
get get very nice axis here to d6
while alaresa doesn't really have any
squares here in
in the center and that could definitely
be quite
a problem so here i would think that
white is doing quite well perhaps even
clearly better so
c4 bishop c2 already it's not looking
too good for
for allareza he needs to be slightly
careful a5 a4
and after a4 magnus gets a grip on
on b5 he's even sometimes he can play b3
to open up for the bishop and
indeed what happens in the game here
queen b6 b3
and alareza takes we can simply play
rook b1 and in the future we'll take
back with the queen
we got to be a little bit careful with
taking back with the bishop though
because sometimes 94 could come
but this is a very very very good for
for magnus
so alareza played knight e4 a more
kind of a more forcing approach bishop
takes c4 he takes it for knight t2
she takes b3 and rook b1 a very very
good move uh black's not doing very well
his development is
not looking too good and indeed it will
be too difficult for black to
um to defend some of these sponsors so
magnus is simply going to take the pawn
and play rook b5 and take that pawn as
well
also the palm of e4 is weak the pawn on
b7 is weak
a lot of lot of weaknesses for alaresa
here
so here i think it could even be winning
objectively for magnus that's how bad
this position is
this is after 20 moves and seemingly
enough
black's moves have been fairly natural
queen g6
rick takes p3 knight f6 and here rook b5
simply attacking the pawn on a5 bishop
e6 lrs
sacrifices the pawn but at least has
finally gotten some development
rick takes a5 knight t5 attacking the
queen
rook takes a8 here it
it's possible to take the queen i still
have my dials though about i still think
this is very good for
for whites but it's not so
simple because there are some tricks
here and
as we know alaresa is very tricky so
maybe this would have been a better
choice but he went for rook takes i8
queen b3 b6 king h2
magnus is stabilizing his position
there's no h5
h4 nonsense and taking on h3
h5 simply queen b5 the plan here is very
straightforward magnus wants to play a5
and start trading some more pieces
we do know that when we're up material
we should try to change as many pieces
as possible
so that's what magnus does he gets this
rook to a5 to a better square
and he has also traded off one of the
pawns and the plan
now is to put more pressure against e4
with the queen b1 as we can see here
knight c3 and now queen b7 once again
putting pressure on
on e4 bishop f5 and here i really like
magnus's move
rook c5 again forcing more exchanges
and he's simply a pawn up so
let's trade and now he has also gotten a
very very strong pass pawn which will
just uh he's just going to push so let's
see what happened
knight e2 queen d5 you never have to
worry about this
there would be no counter play this pawn
is just going to march
march right in queen e6
takes six i take c4 and the magnus is
now up
two pawns and the position is dead lost
for
for black let's see what happened here
bishop d5
knight e6 knight c3 f3
magnus simply wants to play e4 push in
the center
e4 bishop c6 knight f5 knight b5
preventing knight d4
but magnus plays 97 and now it pushes
his pawn to
c6 awfully close to the magic c8 square
knight a7 c7 bishop d7
and here knight g5
g4 controlling more squares it's very
hard for black's king as well to
to get into the game king f7 bishop c5
now even bishop f8 is sometimes an idea
bishop c6 f4
bishop b5 f5 you see magnus now controls
the g6 square and the e6 square
and he also kind of makes it very hard
for this king to go to d7 as i did
mention bishop f8 is an idea
always in the air so bishop d3 but
simply knight b6
this end game here is completely lost
because aliresa's bishop and the king
get completely overwhelmed so let's see
what happens bishop a6
bishop d4 magnus is now simply going to
create a second pass pawn
and it's going to be too much for ali
raza so
uh g6 king g3 takes takes
king of king f4 he's gonna win the pawn
at c7 but it doesn't help
against these two bad boys right here
it's going to be too difficult to stop
for allareza even with the opposite
color bishops g5
kingdom 7 g6 king e8 king g5
the plan is very simple we're just going
to put the bishop on a square that
controls f8 and then push
f6 f7 and then f8
bishop c3 bishop c4 f6
and now the only thing we need to be
careful of is that we can control the f7
square with
the king and that's uh simple enough in
this case
we're just going to put our king on e7
and there is nothing that alareza can do
about it
after bishop b3 king f4 he resigned
because he noticed that king e5 king d6
and king e7 is inevitable
so he
threw in the in the towel and i must say
this is just a brilliant game from
magnus
absolutely it totally screams
magnus when you look at this game so
when you take a look at this game
casually you just
you just think to yourself hmm where did
black even
where did he go wrong all of a sudden he
was just losing and
indeed that's how magnus does it
but um i guess now that we took a look
at it we can't answer that question
the plan with uh bishop e4 and c5
especially with with c5 bishop b4 was
actually a good move
was the plan of c5 was just too
too ambitious and it left too many
weaknesses
and the black's cap that magnus
exploited
masterfully so great game by
uh by the world champion who now has 3.5
out of five points after the first
day also solid result by ferusha as well
who's at two and a half out of five and
at eighth
place